hagar this is kevin d hi kappa b I have
a question
promise is talking prop gun and an act
curious what was your experience like
and if I promised a little improv
restricted budget
I would much as an actor I think most
actors would rather improv probably at
least maybe film actors in theaters a
different animal but I really um it was
good and bad and one respect the
improvising was amazing because you can
you really if if you really understand
your character than the words that come
out if you are organic and literally you
know closer to your heart then if
someone else wrote those words but on
the other side it's like you know you do
you get through an improvised film and
then really got to get back to the real
world with other films and read a script
and adhere to a script so it's like you
kind of get a little rusty you know get
a little used to not reading words of
somebody else and saying so but um I tie
as an actor I really would prefer
improvising and it's interesting with I
mean comedic improvising is tough it's
really tough me personally as an actor I
I am
I'm invigorated when i get to improvise
but how about you do you like
improvising a rigid rather read a script
I think the constable right
yeah I think most of that doesn't say
that I mean I can't imagine that actor
saying I would rather read someone
else's right and then give what I have
to offer through through a character
with whatever comes to mind because
improvising it's like whatever you're
inspired to in a moment but you could do
that with strip to films as well and I
think someone said the mat the magical
moments in film are the unplanned
moments which is true like if you think
about all the magical moments and felt a
most of them would be like something
that was organic or in the moment or
improvised or an unplanned
you